what you were doing it's so shameful now
just i thought about it a lot and
uh i've decided i'm i'm not coming back
to ethiopia
what oh no you heard her clearly i'm not
coming back to ethiopia and y'all she's
serious
ari tells binyam the last thing he
wanted to hear after finding out he's
been having parties and other women at
their house
is it normal in your culture to sleep
with other women when you're engaged and
guess who told her
his own sister but before you say what
if wish is just being messy
ari has receipts he got a message from a
girl saying
we're gonna talk about it plus i want to
win
my
life
steven didn't care if he could sing or
not
[Music]
he got on the piano and proposed to
alina and she said yes
although she was just upset about
messages he sent to another girl he just
asked if
she wants him to come over if she wants
him to stay tonight
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
this show can be such a roller coaster
ride one week i'm crying for binyam and
the next i'm like what are you doing bro
i thought you wanted to keep your family
i was rooting for you we were all
rooting for you how dare you
right it's been two months since i came
to the us for obvious surgery and since
then things have really deteriorated
between benny and i all right before ari
called binyum to tell him that she is
not coming back to ethiopia she revealed
that she's been receiving calls from
people saying binyam has been throwing
parties at their house
the house her parents helped them get
we moved into a three-bedroom house
together it's been really hard for me
because there's like almost nowhere so
my parents have been helping us
and then because vinnie's photos are
being synced to my icloud i'm seeing all
kinds of people
even faces i've never seen before in and
out of my house
so basically he's doing what he wants to
do and being messy with it
alright let's get into that combo a lot
was said plus ari revealed her plans now
that she's not going back to ethiopia hi
hey
how are you
hey okay you look tired she's tired of
the drama binyum plus
never tell a woman that i don't care
especially not your woman clearly you
don't care how i am
you know you haven't called
you know you haven't asked about avi you
don't you don't ask me how i am you turn
the phone off
because every time you ask me about some
situation did you find it why are you
closing why
kept coming with the generic excuses for
a minute
even though it's clear he's just
enjoying his freedom it got to a point
where he didn't even believe what he was
saying
why should i trust you binyam you don't
answer the phone when i call you
for 14 hours for 14 hours you're doing
music
no
something that really upset ari is when
she saw a photo of their bedroom i don't
know who was sleeping in my bed and she
noticed benjamin took down avi's bed and
put it away maybe he didn't want to
think about avi anyways i'm calling i
wanted to tell you something
okay
he knew it was coming i decided i'm i'm
not coming back to ethiopia
i'm not coming back to ethiopia who are
you you just decided for other people
your decision i don't like is not for my
cultures
respectful
stop using your culture as an excuse the
problem is that he thought he could do
what he wanted to do without any
repercussions
is it normal in your culture to sleep
with other women when you're engaged is
that normal
he laughed that question off binyam went
on to say that it's wrong for ari to
decide not to come back to ethiopia
without including him but you can't
expect someone to give you authority
when you're out here making reckless
decisions i mean did he not know his
phone was stinks aries and then because
vinnie's photos are being synced to my
icloud that's how she also found out
about this girl he met at the club i had
his messenger on my phone
and he got a message from a girl saying
do you remember me from the other night
at the club
obviously he's hiding something oh and
then his sister wished hold on him which
i'm not sure how i feel about that she
was looking out but being messy at the
same time sneaky sneaky sir wish is the
one who told me that you had other women
in my house and that you've been around
with other girls you know for for the
health and safety of your family you
should consider getting tested
what
what
mini sister wish texted me and told me
there were girls sleeping over the house
ari told that man to go get tested she
keeps insinuating that he cheated but
you can tell that she does not want to
ask him directly
which leads us to the kicker i am going
to give you a chance although ariella is
not going back to ethiopia she's going
to give binyam one last opportunity to
keep his family but he has to move with
her and avi to kenya so i've decided to
go to the neighboring country of kenya
yes
kenya
oh wow i can't believe that i don't know
why at this point she just won't stay
home
another country she's more interested in
saving him than he is and saving himself
[Music]
me and avi and you can move to mombasa
and we can start over again all right
ari says kenya is neutral territory
that's where avi was conceived it's
ethiopia's neighboring country and
binyan will be away from the evil that's
influencing him right now if you don't
want to come to kenya we can figure out
a custody arrangement and we can
co-parent together that's those are the
options binyam told ari that she's being
bossy and he didn't like it
that's when she pulled out that finger
and gave him the fire a lot of people
would have given him a long time ago let
me tell you something vina you listen to
me
shut up shut up
and listen
you have spent the last two months
destroying your family you don't get a
say anymore you have sacrificed nothing
you have god knows who you
and god knows what you've been doing and
i don't even care and i don't even want
to know
this is your last
chance
so wake up
i'm done with him
i've never heard ari speak to binyam
like that this is your last
chance part of me still loves you
even though you hurt me i am trying to
help you honestly binyam should be
extremely grateful that he has someone
who cares for him so much that she's
willing to work with him as he matures
into the man that he has potential to be
because the reality is there is no
guarantee that he will get there
but
she believes in him
or at least she's trying to
her faith in me really assures me that
she's the girl i want to be with forever
because who else would believe in me
like that speaking of extreme belief
after stressing alina out by
communicating with other girls online
what you see
he just asked if
she wants him to come over if she wants
him to stay tonight they called each
other like
i don't know some cute names steven
finally deleted his social media
accounts after alina asked him to a
number of times
and a few days later he put together
this elaborate proposal on a boat next
to a beautiful waterfall and performed a
song that he wrote for elena
[Music]
your
life
so i got
to ask
ask you to
ask
it's
probably the greatest achievement of my
life to propose to alina while the
proposal was sweet alina
will you marry me
and very steven i ask you two men
i don't know what was going on there
it's perfect
i just couldn't help but wonder how
alina's mom reacted to the news she
probably was like no
[Music]
forget marriage her mom didn't even want
steven to be alina's boyfriend due to
his behavior
but hey elena is truly a hopeless
romantic i believe in some kind of a
fairy tale she's 20 years old beautiful
smart sweet and for some reason she
wants steven to be the one so bad
if only she understood that she has time
there is no rush
all right well next week it looks like
ari and benyam are reuniting in kenya
i'm scared to see him he doesn't seem
like the same person that i left and i
don't know what to expect
i came for fixing for my relationship
i'm very very sorry for you
and the lights that you are gonna have
[Music]
oh
you know based off social media it seems
like they are still together in real
time so if that's the case
i can't wait to see how they manage to
work through all of this
all right 90 day fans fam in the
meantime make sure you stick with et
because we are covering it all i will
see you next time
[Music]
you